Windell they come with a double back out
to Kobe his dried right on in the crowd
boo and make that pass
darling long distance knocks it down
young man young man I like what I'm
seeing so far
darlin there's a six second difference
between shot clock and game clock and
garlic this first a before gals so the
rumors about his uniforms city official
lob to Thompson
Cavaliers cut the lead to a dozen
season is often the core another three
other guesses hero gives Dillon Brooks
turns the corner puts it up at school
others first
this Toronto / plam allows him to get it
down on the deck and go off the glass
none is how Lauren is a gifted playmaker
but turns it over here comes Winslow
racing with Jackson grabbing the bag
this will challenge getting out in
transition
look at the steel pipe and jumping in
front of Jackson junior hero for Navi
yes sir the defense forcing the turnover
is getting out into that passing lane is
bam and we've seen him distribute so
well as a big guy
gorgeous shuffle pass Tyler here Oh such
a nice meal for the as the Fighting
Irish is point guard now back to our
point guard John potty along with Eric
Green tell me Thank You Jax here's Tyler
hero the rookie with his second score of
is opening night sharp five points for
hero you'll get less and less call from
efficient then they see you take your
body to the defendant John Moran bling
together a lineup of a couple of rookies
here's Moran good interior D Barrett
goes at Lyles
girl step layup his girl sweet move from
a rookie allows a Canadian player like
Barrett his versatility busted Knicks
there he creates him of the years at
Spurs a lot of his teammates have picked
up the slack here's Barrett Barrett
drives and finishes once again Barrett
in double figures with 11
there have been bedeviled by travelling
rolls lady looking to posted totes
there's a double good ball movement but
deflected by Payton here's Barrett
Barrett goes right at Forbes gets inside
and finishes just over my cousin while
the winning part Rebecca that's the key
he he's played now this is a sixth year
in a league shot inside Barrett with the
finish mantle is not only is he never
been to the playoffs yet his first
five-year played on a winning team he
wants to taste those postseason he wants
to play the winning team Randall pokes
it away defensive play
here comes Barrett Barrett trying to go
coast-to-coast beautiful feed the bobby
portis miss that three of nine
rudy Gay been stolen by Payton his fort
Steele of the game finds Barrett Barrett
with the flush wild third quarter
turnovers igniting both team ferret gets
inside and scores at the buzzer goes
right at Derek white a very good
defender